all right so this episode is brought to
you by magic and I'm joined here today
with Danny Machuca and we'll be going
over some of his games and so today
we'll go over two of his games one of
them was from tournament the pill right
st. Louis open that he had just played
this is his first round game against a
player that's rated about 1450 or so and
in that game
Danny played d4 so he has the white
pieces and his opponent played f5 and
you said you've played this this fella
before yeah we played in a blitz game
some radio blitz tournament and he also
played the Dutch I'm not used to playing
d4 so much so I had played a little bit
dubiously the last time I did win but
not because of the opening he was
actually probably winning at the last
game we played in our blitz so I had
improved it did you play Knight to c3 in
them that blitz candidate yes I did okay
so far this isn't chess openings
explained so we'll kind of breeze
through the opening here so we have we
got a Dutch with Knight to c3 and in
this position d5 is a perfectly good
move it's actually a really solid way to
play and he decided to play the movie
six yeah and our last game actually
instead of Bishop e5 I played the
dubious e4 because there's a five minute
game first of all and yeah it was 1400
so right hello would do be a stop today
I played more mainline okay thank ya so
this position I mean e4 it just makes
the most sense
yeah with Bishop c4 played though right
yes yeah so okay he took back and now he
broke the pin so he's starting to just
take your knife yeah and this is all
booked in right so sorry I missed so he
took he took it right back and now you
plate you surprised me you played it
move it I didn't really know but it's
probably okay well I played Knight f3
yeah I've had this position many times
since now I play against the Dutch as
well and I've always played Knight f3 in
this position and okay play might
continue like this and okay we'd like
develop pieces and it usually ends up
where it wakes like a little bit better
it's often black Oh play d5 and then
you can either move away or you can take
so you can get a position like this
where white is is feeling pretty good
he's got control over 85 and okay so
he's probably a little bit better than
the bishop it's probably not the not the
greatest piece over there but okay I'm
just gonna do the little French yeah
yeah what the Dutch yeah no these are
the French maneuver it's also French
black got in the f6 break early and so
okay it's off well he didn't play c5 but
it's all good yeah very similar okay but
instead Dani played a different move so
let's go back what moved to Dani Machuca
playing let's get the audience involved
here Mike come on in my audio whoa big
check
did you did you slam that as loud as my
comer what a slam dinner is booked Leo
sorry I thought he knew about it yeah
okay so some of g6 and okay it kind of
looks like maybe white is in a little
bit of trouble you know we got this this
pawn is attacked your queen is attacked
I mean what are you gonna do are you
gonna take the bishop and play Queen d1
that would obviously be very bad for
that week
yeah so Danny decides to offer a
sacrifice Queen to h6
which i think is the right way to play
and here black should probably just
continue getting on with life you know
just give us Queen out or do something
there
yeah I I didn't expect him to play
Bishop takes d4 that was have you
studied did you know this position um
yeah I'd only actually look basically up
to here and then I you guys I'm still
kind of getting into before so I'm more
no II for Lions deeper but okay here I
had set a up to this point because of
our last match and I had taken a look a
little bit that I'm supposed to play h4
and h5 but I mean all the examples I
looked at no one was brave enough will
say to take the d4 pawn
okay so you kind of knew there was I do
it was wrong no yeah I just didn't know
exactly my New Castle and I was
like okay that's what's what you do okay
and yeah I mean it looks it looks quite
dangerous to take that pond if you just
look at this entire quadrant over here
it looks a bit fishy for black and
alright you just might is gonna be able
to give us pieces out he does have the
idea that was mentioned but not played
of h4 h5 that's usually uh yeah so I
thought that's yeah I wasn't quite sure
if he does take on d4 do I still plays
for h5 where do I go for just more
development because like he's lacking
development even more yeah I thought
both ways are okay I now thinking
yeah probably torn a tribe even now
after victor takes d4 it's probably
still just the best move okay so he
decided to go back which i think makes
sense you kind of wanna keep control
over g7 I mean if you go back way to
start the sneak in here so I think this
could be
yeah I'm sure I'm sure I'm sure his plan
was to eventually play rook e8 or queen
e7 and physically stay on and try to
kick me out which he did in the game but
okay squared away that makes makes the
bookends it's the square beyond compare
that's Mario Roper ladies and gentlemen
okay so very good and yes I think maybe
again h4 whatever I don't really
remember
- I have three here yeah and then he
played just some move yes so um the
mattress I remember this game from the
post-mortem yeah so yeah he did play b6
first mom which okay okay it knows now
that you played Mitchell c4 yeah
pictures before alright we'll see if the
audience can see the threat Danny just
made a threat what did he do who can
find it does anyone see the move here
all right didn't even more people you
have to got even more people to help us
out now no you're fine all right does
anybody see it do I have to give away a
really big hand let's see we got that oh
we got a pin
we got a pin here we got the big pin
that's hopefully you see it at home but
he's just simply threatening to I take
that biggie pawn here so that's that's
the threat and his opponent got out of
that threat
okay um I wonder - did you did you
calculate this move at all
Bishop to b7 yeah I was looking at it I
actually thought is gonna be his first
choice to be honest did you consider
Bishop takes you six here cuz I was yeah
that's what I was considering I hadn't
quite come to a conclusion because as I
recall it played fairly quickly you have
anybody quickly play considering fairly
quickly not like evidently but yeah I
ain't quite time but okay fine or even
some other lines I mean I should be
winning this position yeah yeah it just
feels like so right that this must be
just crushing I'm all like yeah I didn't
calculate so much as just everything out
right work out okay so instead obviously
a good move here getting out of the pen
very normal and then Danny did something
that just to prove that he's a good
player he used all of his pieces
so you'll notice Danny has all of his
pieces out and he's castled
and every one of his pieces is great and
black has two pieces out and his King is
not cancelled and it's not great so we
got huge pressure here there's probably
just totally winning at this point I
mean this is just he wouldn't get spread
of sure she'll have to remind me what he
did here to be he played pickup job Evan
and I played Queen afore okay which adds
right I guess two points to it when
you're preventing castling but you're
also taking aim over here at this C pawn
yeah and I thought he was gonna stock
the pawn actually I thought he was gonna
play Knight
six I mean if you're behind the
development there's only one here which
is just you develop your pieces oh yeah
this is bad for him buddy
he's not in the center anymore caught up
in development and was still better if
not winning still but if the game goes
on and yeah okay
yeah like that one one funny thing that
I that I wish would happen here is I
hope he goes like this and let's just
waste waste of turns here think it's
sort of like the Danny which you've got
rope you know you like these bricks are
stuck behind upon I mean that's just a
funny idea that might happen to the
position but yeah you should probably
think about just giving that pawn back
instead okay you might here now he
played here no no he played he sings he
played yeah he played yeah yeah
v6 which unfortunately is completely
losing and there's there's a lot of
really good moves here so let's take a
look here out in the audience and see
who can figure this out I mean all of
your pieces are in proper place here if
you're white so it's time for that the
magic to happen here so let's see
there's there's more than one right
answer but wouldn't you guys play here
has played well there's lots of
sacrificial ideas in this position the
absolute computer move would have been a
fantastic move but I I assume you you
didn't calculate they're just like in
reading the game but if you found the
move Bishop to d5 then thank you grants
that's a that's a yeah I mean that's all
that computer show me that up okay well
okay right yeah I mean it makes sense
that there's because I would win I had
just been focusing on like the face
screws over there yeah so one point is
yeah after they take and we can put our
Knight anywhere do you recall the
computer number that he gave the should
be five or sons oh yeah busy you know
yeah this is like plus five your move
was like plus three okay so there's
another move those also like plus three
so and that so this sacrifice this also
was a good move but Danny went in Farook
takes d6 and then his opponent blunder
at big time yeah okay okay so I guess
what we should show what happens if they
take this which I assume you got really
good yeah nice Shack and then
he moves the King and they play rugby
one player to one that a midnight f7 no
I'd rather get my trip d1 what do you
want I think is better probably
obviously I'm gonna stop there yeah yeah
for time but yeah this is this is lost
yeah looks pretty bad but the move that
black played here was even worse than
anything else
yeah Bishop d7 just that was his last
move now Danny played to move that even
this audience will be able to solve so
what did Mike play in this situation
yeah new faces let's go Bishop to b5
yeah you love giving a little check
there it oh do something walk
not quite up community yeah just
probably just crushing out well you
haven't even simpler move the win
immediately in the back alright
excellent move whoever that guy is he's
a genius and this was the final move of
the game so yeah he actually defends to
us you thought for a while okay resign
um yeah I was really shocked that he
would make that blunder in the Blitz
game he played much better yeah I don't
think he blundered a single piece until
like a very very end but yet so yeah so
this is shock me
okay so I guess I via tend to give a
little summary of the game I guess what
would you say how did you how did you
win this game whether they happened oh
so I know the opening can do the open I
knew I just knew the ideas and I want to
deviate I spent time on I liked how to
punish women then okay so yeah it helps
to know the openings versus just making
up that one spot yeah great and it's it
was a great example of one side using
all of their pieces and the other side
not fully developed and immediately
there was some sacrifices as soon as
everybody was ready to go so a really
nice game here by our good friend Danny
Machuca and we're gonna show one more
game now we're gonna go back into
Annie's history and we look at a famous
game from the Machuca massacre which is
a real thing you're on the internet you
can google that the Pachuca massacre so
Danny played a tournament it was in LA
yeah it was in passed up Arcadia Arcadia
yeah and so he he went six for six
this was when he was about 1700 some low
1700 and he went six for six including
beating three experts and he went like
straight to 1900 something's okay over
200 point yeah just from this just one
tournament and it was a great tournament
I've watched all of his games and he
really it really was a massacre he
hacked and slaved and crushed everybody
it was fantastic and I guess back in the
day you must have played efore a lot
more cuz you were white in this game
well so I've only been playing before
since I moved here and even then only
half and half maybe even less yeah
because the Danny I know is like very
positional and moves his pieces around
slow
yeah because I think okay so after this
after this tournament I mean I started
thinking that uh I need I need to
increase my positional play I can't just
go on these dubious sacrifices that they
do work here but like Magna Clee they're
they're not that sound and you know well
yeah okay and I thought this was your
last run game where you think this was
actually a fifth round this is this was
a bit round game okay I looked it up
yeah excellent
and so we got the Sicilian and Danny was
in a really fighting move cuz he played
the move d4 right so not that the normal
Sicilian we're gonna get a Smith more a
gambit here and after c3 your opponent
accepted which is strange - thank you
are telling me that he was trying to
just get some closed position and trade
later
yeah later on in this game he makes he
returns to pawn and I think it's because
the the few rounds before this I had
been winning by just stacking everything
and like just going crazy and so I think
maybe he even prepared the the
followings that give back to these I'm
not sure um but yeah maybe you should
have played other lines to d3 probably
would have been instead of accepting
again right if you wanted to not accept
it in the first place yeah there's a lot
of pouring ways you can play against the
Smith more ya ticket to that would you
like which is part of the reason I don't
play Smith more anymore because after
you study the lines it it's kind of
dubious thank you all right and then he
played a move that kind of surprised me
g6 which is not a very common move
normally in these positions black is
just trying to get consolidate get all
this pieces out well I can speak
advantage is that he's gonna be able to
develop his pieces rather quickly and
he's gonna be able to castle and get his
queens and his other fish up and ropes
into the game it's all gonna happen
really really fast so black normally
adopts a pawn structure with d6 and e 6
included and then the bishop just goes
to e7 you try to get your pieces out and
Castle and if Wade doesn't make anything
of his development advantage then you
just you just win cuz rep upon but white
uh it's a strike first
so it seems strange to play g6 although
I mean it's it's it's got to be playable
but now whenever this Bishop goes
to see for which it's likely to do black
has to be a little bit worried about his
dark squares if he's thinking about
planning to move like e6000 Annie just
gets his pieces out and okay so we can
see white has a nice development lead
black is still up upon and one problem
is if we can only just bring our night
out to f6 then we'd be looking pretty
good but you always have to worry about
the move e5 and then black played a move
that surprised me here as well I feel
like black wants to get the moves d6 and
Knight to c6 in just really controlling
the e5 square so then you can get your
knight on g8 out and you just get to
castle and you'll get some Sun position
but here he played a six so again you
know not doing anything with the central
pawns not getting another piece out and
Dany wisely just castles okay and here
black finally goes ahead and gets d6 in
okay and then I really like to this move
the Dany played but do anything like it
um I thought is a practical choice but
yeah it's probably not that good of a
move okay I thought three pieces and you
know yeah I'm not sure this is this is
actually that good and it's why I have
to sort of stop trying to play crazy
guys no way you know because they
shouldn't shouldn't work at he played
better people okay I thought this was
was a great move because yeah you're
just threatening to positionally weaken
the structure and then you know your
Knights just gonna come into d5 you
should get a get a really good game one
point to mention is blacks should not
think about taking this either way
because now White has a very typical
tactic does anybody see what up with
white should play in this position
Bishop takes f7 right and then removing
the defender of the Queen so this would
lose out right so he really can't you
know just move his pawn I assumed he
would just play some normal move but
that didn't that didn't happen and then
one point is if you do play this
variation you do get this this really
nice weakness here and I assume after a
move like Knight to d5 you're you're
doing great your roof will be able to
come in you know your Bishop will be
able to either attack this week fawn or
it'll be able to come in here and look
at some of these dark squares and
obviously you're threatening Knight to
c7 in this position I thought this would
just be great for you I didn't really
know what black was gonna do in position
like this yeah yeah but still I think I
think you should still play 96 and said
oh well yeah right so here's what he
actually played let's go back a move
here okay so after he five black played
a move that I didn't like at all
d5 so he's trying to give the the pawn
back just to get some of his pieces out
and get castled here so there's three
ways you can take but I like taking with
the knife I think that makes no sense
yeah I don't when he when he sacked his
pawn I was kind of confused but now I
understand he was just trying to trade
off the Queen's here and he Don he was
he daughters perforce that after you
know e six trade I think he thought
horse
and yeah so e six breaking one of my
rules so in general whenever you open
one of the doors for your Bishop your
Bishop started here on the FA so they
already opened one door and now he's
opened a second which means there's
gonna be weak dark squares on some side
of the board since this Bishop went out
here protecting some of the dark squares
on the Kings side some of the dark
squares in the Queen side slash center
will be a little bit weaker in some of
these variations because you don't have
a bishop over there and now another
another nice move I could like this move
Bishop g5 so he's doing a good job just
getting all of his pieces out we we're
noticing a trend in Danny's play if
there's one thing that Danny's good at
which is probably the number of things
that you're good at yeah it's you get
all of your pieces out and all of your
games so that's that's that's the one
thing you do really well
and now my comment should probably avert
his eyes cuz he's not kind of like the
next move even though it's probably the
best move it's probably the only move
all right we got a little f6
so we got your notations you mentioned
this move this must've been something
you analyzed I know I thought during the
game so before I played mixergy 5 I made
sure Queen 85 wasn't a thing I mean you
would have been bad anyway but we should
see what what the audience thinks of
this move so white here has a nice
little little tactic see who can see it
so it's I mean it's based on the fact
that man we got a lot of a lot of good
stuff going on in life and we can almost
play here except for dying the Queen so
who can who can distract the Queen
or awesome awesome before and then I
like the line that you you gave here not
clean to a three so you're like Queen to
a four you know oh come and get me
don't get me come get me but white
hasn't even better move so yeah he's
hoping he's hoping you just take the
Queen because I mean you don't get
checkmated but uh okay after this move
you're just getting checkmated I guess
you didn't even give the line but the
follow-up is presumably here yeah I mean
okay so instead let's say we got f6 and
you took with the night which I was
pretty confused
I mean taking at the pawn look pretty
good thing you didn't like everything
looks pretty good
like I thought my first thought I don't
know what no yeah it looks great a
little than that okay they all look
pretty good
oh that's a tough choice yeah it's hard
one like every move is so good yeah are
you gonna pick the right one
those are the hardest times to decorate
yeah okay you took with the night check
I assumed you expected that you've taken
with the bishop or who knows yeah I know
again there's so many lines but they all
seem just winning cuz this gangs on
center right all right so you took back
and then he he was like so happy I got
the Queen's off yeah but he hasn't done
any of his pieces out in the game yeah
and like this this is really weak and
this is really strong so okay and I
think here you played another great move
isn't he yeah he's trying to lock it
down and get that well okay okay yeah
because you know all the stuff he never
wants to move any of his pieces
that's like as cool I guess make sure I
like Nemo there all right there it's
easier to set it back up at the end and
you played a good move but in your notes
you gave an even better move so let's I
have spent I wish I had the notes
exactly but I think I spend maybe 12 15
maybe even 20 minutes running most of my
time on should I play 95 and that looked
like a better move but it was just so
complicated versus the simple loop that
I played there
that you know okay but we're winning
maybe one was winning more but I I could
only I saw more clearly the the line I
played and so okay they're both winning
play the clear line and this is what
happened to you in the tournament the
other day the time where you spent and
you spent twenty minutes thinking about
a move you didn't play the best move
that's exactly exactly well sometimes I
back out cuz so okay I went home and the
game I lost sight I looked at my
computer I was like oh i that was a move
i was looking at the computer suggestion
right that holds the draw and then I was
like you overthought I only bought it so
she just played my first move okay so we
can explain for a second why this move
is uh just so deadly why this is just
just crushing if we make any move here
for black I don't know what you guys
want to look like let's take this for
example
the audience is outraged so we can take
here and so obviously if you go here
where we're bringing the rook in and
then won't be able to get a queen and if
you play here it looks like you did the
same thing only it's not check and now
you're you know now you go in here yeah
and this yeah I mean it's easy when
we're moving the pieces what it has it
is important like I'm investing
everything in there man winning for the
gym what what if I'm wrong you know like
so yeah I didn't trust myself that much
and I play does maybe the second best
move I'm not sure all right so let's
take a look at what he did play but I
did single-handed uh playing rook d8
check you blundered you're up Danny how
are you
I can't fool ready okay so black took it
and hopefully now we see what White's
gonna play in this position hopefully
you see it at home
f7 your favorites quitter it knows what
check yeah alright you do put the king
yeah that's he didn't did he resign yet
no he played on played on and let's see
what Danny is all of his pieces who know
all right so first you attack that
little rook over there ya go rook attack
and now you bring all your pieces in wow
you did it again yeah you use all of
your pieces and then you know most of
this entire Queen side over here is just
just sitting here idle you gotta get out
of check and from here it's it's a
pretty simple win so you took here
defending
you're very awesome on here on f7 you
know there's pens and all of your pieces
are pinned and all they're all attacked
and he played b6 I think this is his
intention is to defend with ya rook day
7 ah and now you just bring your other
piece in I mean all your pieces are
great there's a great piece of very good
eek yeah okay so he didn't defend and
Danny played one more move and I saw
there's a lot of good moments like I'm
sure he thought I was gonna do the
double pack and like trade this stuff
which it I'm just a wonder what ideas
hotel oh yeah I thought he was gonna you
know nice e6 is what he thought was
happening right and obviously it's all
winning of what it's crushing it's not
as good as I think I think it's not to
do this with my plate so what was the
even better move that Danny Machuca
found so not Knight to c6 which looks
absolutely crushing but an even more
accurate move cuz Danny is a chess
artist
I assume you spent a lot of time here on
the absolute best most accurate move I
mean I when he played 21 of you before
you even played rookie 7 I hadn't seen
that I do it though it's kind of easy
all stuff Jordan where d7 97 room t7
yeah a sacrifice all right was I did you
ever follow up yeah okay so he played an
even better move we'll go ahead and give
it away
he took instead on g6 and then he
resigned oh yeah I mean okay I mean yeah
the best might be like taking this which
you don't want it okay and then
yeah actually I actually was kind of
surprised he had he had resigned at this
point Bruce its I mean befall is before
he was losing so I thought he's gonna
keep going until I and I thought this is
the hardest part like I was you know
gonna be the artist because I can't keep
going forward anymore I'm a sport it's
like so you know yes I said yeah you
could just win lots of material and
someone will be out there holding
something something takes night yeah
exactly
so I mean like it's tricky I expect it
and play on all right well thanks a lot
Danny it's been a pleasure having you
here to analyze some of these game thank
you I hope you enjoyed that yogurt I did
so tell us what you thought about this
video do you like seeing that the double
commentary videos maybe we can do that
again in the future and keep submitting
your games - info at st. Louis chess
club org and perhaps we'll get to
analyze some of your games so thanks
everybody for coming out thanks for
watching online hit like subscribe share
etc we'll see you guys next time